今天我們會講一下聖經末世的預兆
先來「每日一字」，這裡有兩個字
哪一個是「末」字呢?
我覺得中國人是很有智慧的
你發覺「末」字上面比較長、下面比較短
你發覺是不是好像越走越窄，走到一個盡頭那樣
相反，「未」字就是上面比較窄、下面比較闊
越走越闊，豁然開朗，有一個新的境界
這兩個字都可以代表我們今天聚會的盼望
盼望你的人生從末日轉為未來
從窮途末路
進到這個燦爛的未來
不知道大家有沒有留意一些新聞
有時候有些新聞裡面有些很嚇人的景象
有時候會用「末日」去形容
譬如這幅照片，你看見是幾年前
2017年，報道說山火
燒得很厲害，沖天的煙霧
又例如半年前
在印尼婆羅洲的森林大火
燒得很厲害
其實那是在白天
但是整個天空都紅了
有些人形容紅得好像世界末日
又好像最近的疫情
在南韓大邱市
因為有爆發，整個城市都沒什麼人
冷清得就像末日一樣
有時候一些報道有意無意間都提到聖經
這就是一個星期前的一則新聞
講到有個警告，就是將來世界會有饑荒
那他怎麼形容呢?
他說是聖經級的大饑荒
即是一個 Famine of Biblical Proportions
甚至一隻牛犢出生
這裡都講到會惹起末日的憂慮
這些新聞一會兒我們有機會可以重溫一下
在疫情裡面我曾經見過這幅照片
我覺得幫這些石頭戴口罩的人也是有心
不過我就想起那八個字
就是「真神造人、假神人造」
如果這些石頭真的會感染病毒倒還好
但是假神是人造的
真神是造人的
祂既然造人
人有理智
有分析能力
而這位神當然也有
祂給我們很多證據
讓我們在理智上知道祂的真實
祂的存在
祂的寶貴
其中一個證據就是聖經
聖經裡面充滿了預言
有人統計過
聖經有超過四分之一的篇幅是預言
顧名思義，預言的意思是一件事還未發生
就預先講了出來
到了時候
真的這樣發生
其實透過預言
使我們知道神是真實的
聖經裡面講的那位是真神
同時
也希望我們有所預備
特意預備
滿天烏雲
如果你出門
那你是不是會帶把傘
所以同樣，透過預言，神也想我們有所預備
到底聖經裡面有沒有說到關乎末日、末世的事呢?
兩千年前，當主耶穌在地上的時候
有一次祂和門徒在一起
門徒就問了主耶穌一個這樣的問題
他們說什麼呢?
他們說：請你告訴我們，你降臨和世界的末了有什麼預兆
聖經真的告訴我們有世界末了
不過我想強調
這個「世界末了」並不是說 The end of the world
所有人都死了
如果你看英文就更加清楚了
這裡說什麼呢?
The end of the age
一個時代的完結
聖經說到「世界末了」，是說一個時代、一個階段的完結
這個完結牽涉到什麼呢?
就是主耶穌的降臨
原來主耶穌會再一次回來
祂要開始一個新的時代
主接著就回答門徒
祂說什麼呢?
就著他們問關於末世有什麼預兆
主就說了
祂說：你們要謹慎
因為將來有些人會冒我的名
甚至說自己是基督
並且要迷惑許多人
你們也會聽見打仗和打仗的風聲
民要攻打民
國要攻打國
多處有饑荒、地震
這些都是災難的起頭
但我想你留意一下
「災難」原文作「生產之難」
意思是什麼呢?等於一個女人生孩子
你發覺當她快要臨盆的時候
這些陣痛會越來越頻密
越來越厲害
這個就是「生產之難」的意思
就是說你看到的不單只是這些跡象
並且這些跡象會越來越頻密
越來越厲害
剛才我們是不是有留意那則新聞
南韓的大邱，市中心好像都沒有人了
其實為什麼呢?
因為當時在大邱有這個嚴重的爆發
而這個爆發主要是牽涉到一些大型的聚會
我想你在報道裡面聽過了
就是所謂新天地教會
不知道你知不知道
這個創辦人自稱自己是耶穌基督
原來在南韓自稱自己是耶穌基督的人有二十多個
又真的有很多人聽他們的
其實2020年這幾個月世界局勢很緊張
你想想波斯灣的戰爭
美國和伊朗的緊張氣氛
延續到今天四月都仍然戰雲密佈
所以有些人可能新年的願望就是世界和平
聖經講到除了打仗之外
也特別提到有擾亂的事
「擾亂的事」，Commotion，是什麼意思呢?
就是說不單只是剛才講的國要攻打國
民要攻打民
「擾亂的事」就是一些 disturbance
一些騷亂、擾亂
譬如歷時多年的法國黃背心示威
又或者去年香港的反修例抗爭
你發覺在世界各地都有這些騷亂
而這些是會越來越嚴重、越來越厲害的
我不知道這一家牛
有沒有想過這一天
吃著草，突然間周圍的地都凹了下去
其實這幅照片就是有一次紐西蘭地震
周圍的草地就凹了下去
陷成了一個坑
這幅圖片我們看到近一百年
地震的情況
五級以上的地震不是小地震
是大地震
而你看到地震發生的頻率
是越來越多、越來越頻密的
所以還記得「生產之難」嗎
因此，這次的疫情稱為 Pandemic
即是全球大流行
你知道 Pandemic 這個字其實在希臘文的意思
即是 All People
即是牽涉到所有人
你想想，短短兩個月間
已經全世界每一個國家
即是全球都有確診的個案
所以聖經說
多處都有饑荒、瘟疫
你看見
真的是多處
聖經裡面講到瘟疫還有一個特點
除了多處之外
也講到
死的人、被殺的人很多
譬如這節聖經提到
透過刀劍、饑荒、瘟疫被殺的人
甚至多達四分之一
人口
有沒有想過四分之一是什麼意思
全球七十七億人
四分之一即是死了十九億人
即是說中國十三億，加上美國三億多
都不夠填這個數目
其實這幅照片裡面你也可以看見這次的疫情
你看見很多名字
其實這些傳染病全部是2000年之後、即是這二十年裡面發生的
無論霍亂、豬流感、腦膜炎、SARS、麻疹、伊波拉
還有中東的 MERS
這就打破了一個迷思
有些人覺得二十一世紀醫學昌明
不會有這樣的瘟疫
但是你看短短二十年
發生的瘟疫、傳染病很多
而這次這個肺炎
你想想，到3月19號的時候
死了九千人
一個月之後
這就是4月20號
已經由九千人跳到十七萬人了
都相當嚇人
下面的表可以看到，我昨天查過
直到4月30號，全球感染的人超過三百萬
死亡人數有二十三萬多
這個數目當然不小
但如果比較全世界的人口七十七億人
其實染病的人只不過是 0.04%
什麼意思呢?
一萬人只有四人染病
死的人，十萬個裡只有三個
有人這樣說
如果疫情要舒緩
要有群體免疫
可能病毒要傳到六、七成的人
才有機會緩和
由 0.04% 到六、七十%
其實還有很漫長的路
剛才有提到
將來世界可能會有饑荒
為什麼用「聖經級的饑荒」去形容呢?
就是講到這個饑荒很嚴重
還有很多地方會發生
其實我看過一些資料
現在是很嚴重的
是什麼呢?
就是很多地方的農莊、很多農產品
因為疫情的問題
沒有工人去收割
有些收割了卻沒有人來收購
就算收了之後
也沒有運輸
因為沒有飛機
沒有運輸
結果很多農產品就要棄置
比如美國把很多牛奶都倒掉
比如大陸是不是把很多小雞都銷毀了
比如歐洲把很多農產品都要銷毀
你可以預見，在可見的將來
其實將來可能在兩三個月裡面
全球會有饑荒發生
再加上，你可能聽過最近這幾個月
就是有關沙漠蝗蟲
這次的蝗蟲是七十年裡面最嚴重的
影響到譬如非洲的情況
索馬里、肯亞、埃塞俄比亞
影響到阿拉伯半島
甚至蝗蟲飛到巴基斯坦、阿富汗
有人會擔心
到底蝗蟲會不會飛到中國
入侵中國呢?
入侵中國就麻煩大了
這麼多人口
不過也有人這樣說
不怕、不怕、不怕
因為在中國的蝗蟲
是不敢四隻一起飛的
並不是因為有限聚令
而是因為牠們會被拍扁做串燒
那最近還有一則新聞
就是在湄公河下游的五個國家
比如說越南、柬埔寨
泰國、緬甸這些
這些都是傳統的糧倉
但由於湄公河
水量減少
你看那些照片
那個河床都露了出來
令到下游這些國家出現旱災
但這一次
其實並不是天然的
主要是因為中國在雲南建了水壩
用來水力發電
這樣就攔住了那些水
其實這也使我們想到一個問題
其實現在大部分的河流
它的水源都來自高山
譬如青藏高原
而因為全球暖化
使得很多高山上的冰川融化
你可以想像一下
水塔沒有水
下游的河流哪裡有水呢?
如果沒有水
其實農作物就沒法灌溉了
所以這是一個很大的潛在
關乎糧食的危機
不知道大家最近有沒有留意這則新聞
科學家都很緊張
因為在北半球、北極上空
出現了一個很大的臭氧洞
臭氧 Ozone 其實是用來擋住太陽的紫外光
如果紫外光照射到地面
照到人身上可能會引致皮膚癌、白內障
紫外光也同樣會破壞農作物
所以這也會影響到糧食的供應
不過很難得
這個臭氧洞在一個月裡面很快就恢復了
其實最主要的原因是天氣回暖了
想到這裡，我都覺得神真是有憐憫
天氣回暖就使這個臭氧洞很快復合
同時因為天氣回暖
北半球的疫情也有一些緩和的跡象
大家還記得剛才這兩幅照片嗎?
原來聖經裡面講到，在主回來之前的前夕
地要大震動，日頭要變黑好像毛布
滿月變紅好像血
我相信不是太陽或者月亮有什麼問題
我相信是大氣層出了問題
這節聖經之後也這麼提到
它就講到不單止日頭、月亮
它還說天上的星辰都墜落於地
好像無花果樹被大風搖動
落下未熟的果子一樣
可能你會想
什麼星辰墜落?
我相信說的不是金星、火星
如果那些撞下來就完了
在2018年的時候
中國的太空站
天宮一號就走到最後一程了
墜落到這個地球
在大氣層摩擦燃燒
加上解體
你見到那幅照片就是這樣的情況
這就好像眾星墜落
在上個星期
不知道有沒有留意這則新聞
其實有一個叫做「星鏈計劃」
它的計劃裡面
想要升空一萬二千個衛星
用來覆蓋全球
使所有人能夠用手機
直接透過衛星上網
現在已經發射了四百多個衛星
因為你知道，如果它們太高就很難接觸到
所以它們都比較低
距離地面大約300公里左右
二百多英里左右
如果一旦這些衛星出了問題
其實衛星最大的問題不是它的大小
而是它的速度
這些衛星四十五分鐘就環繞地球一周
如果一旦這些衛星有什麼差池
其實同一高度的所有這些衛星就會互相橫掃
就會產生連鎖反應
不知道大家有沒有看過《引力邊緣》(Gravity) 那部電影
它講的就是這個問題
我想如果到時候這樣橫掃
我想滿天都是星辰墜落
又例如這裡提過那隻牛犢出生
為什麼這麼轟動呢?
除了說兩千年來都沒有一隻紅色的牛出生之外
其實最主要就是關乎到以色列人
他們夢寐以求的就是重建聖殿
恢復獻祭
但如果他們要重建聖殿
一定要建在哪裡呢?建在耶路撒冷
就算給他們建好
也都要潔淨聖殿、潔淨祭司才能去獻祭
而那隻紅母牛其實就是用來潔淨的
他們將那隻大約兩三歲的牛燒成灰
用紅母牛的灰潔淨聖殿的器具、潔淨祭司、恢復獻祭
所以兩千年來他們都找不到紅母牛
當紅母牛出現的時候
在很多猶太人心目中，覺得重建聖殿的時候到了
如果你看一下新聞
其實美國最近對以色列的策略不同了
把大使館搬去耶路撒冷
其實他一心想締造中東的和平
所以有沒有聽過「世紀協議」，促成以色列和巴勒斯坦的和議
將來這個和議一定會達成
不過未必是美國主導
當它達成的時候，他們能夠重建聖殿
恢復獻祭，我都很想看到
他們獻牛犢、燒成灰的時候，為什麼呢?
因為從他們選在哪裡獻
也可以讓我們知道
他們心目中聖殿的位置在哪裡
我們就拭目以待
那我們知道，這兩點能夠連成一條直線
如果很多點
都落在一條直線上的時候
我們就會看見
其實這個方向是確定的
當你看見剛才那麼多的跡象
假基督
打仗
騷亂
地震、饑荒、瘟疫
日、月、星的變異
關乎到以色列人
聖殿的重建等等
你發覺這一切所朝著的方向
是什麼呢?
就是主耶穌要回來
主耶穌也快回來了
願我們預備迎見主